wrapping up pet week this morning with
the good people at the animal foundation
joined this morning by ari medecki
the program manager for the shelter's
pet food pantry good morning to you how
are you doing this morning
i'm well good morning thank you so let's
talk about the pet food pantry at the
animal foundation we've profiled a lot
of times the efforts uh to try and make
sure
that pets get fed pet food can get
expensive talk about the effort by the
animal foundation
absolutely the animal foundation is
committed to keeping
every person pet together which is how
we created our kept
program and the mission of the program
is to keep pets
in their loving homes we know how
important
the human animal bond is and we want to
foster that bond at the animal
foundation
so we provide free cat and dog food
to anyone in the las vegas valley who is
in need
we can provide that once every 30 days
and it's just another way to help out in
the community and again to keep pets
in their loving homes with their
families how much of a of a challenge
have you noticed
through the pandemic for pet owners to
to hold on to their animals
when they when they're struggling to
feed themselves to also feed their pets
how much demand are you seeing right now
for that for that help
well we have always known that las vegas
statistically and historically is higher
than the national average when it comes
to
people food insecurity and unemployment
so there's always a need and we have
actually had a consistent need with or
without covid
in terms of families reaching out to us
so we are
always we always know that there's a
need in the community and we always are
striving to meet that need and to remove
whatever challenges might be facing
pet owners in order to obtain food
whether it's transportation
which we are open seven days a week so
that they can come in any of those days
we do
strongly encourage that they make an
appointment but we know that we're
there's always a great need in las vegas
so we're
always up for meeting that challenge and
we're here and available to help pets
and their families
so i'm curious on a monthly basis what
kind of uh reaction or what kind of
demand are you seeing there at the
animal foundation who's showing up
you know it's everyone is showing up we
see all sorts of
individuals and we consider a family one
person with their pet
or uh with mom and dad and kids
so we see everyone and all kinds of
individuals again yeah especially with
kobid
some people may be struggling right now
with an unemployment
um so it's it's pretty much everyone and
anyone
that you can imagine that has come to us
for help and again we do that once every
30 days and they can continue to come to
us
and we're also very lucky community has
stepped up and donated so much food to
us as well so that we've been able to
assist
so many people and that was going to be
my final question if folks want to
donate to try and help the food pantry
at the animal foundation what can they
do
we're always looking and appreciative of
donations they can reach out to
us at our phone number at 702-955-5910
drop off food at our location 655 north
mojave
and again it is cat and dog food and
we're just so appreciative of the
community who always steps up and helps
us
we purchase a lot of the food that we
donate out but we also know that the
community has stepped up quite a bit and
we're so appreciative of that
it is a very worthwhile endeavor to make
sure that pets are being fed by their
owners
when it's a difficult time for a lot of
folks in the valley ari medecki from the
animal foundation and the pet food
pantry thank you for joining us this
morning have a good rest of the day and
take care
thank you